still baffle I like the look at this it
looks like a mini waffle so I'm sold
yes amazing what is in this oh man this
is good
oh look at that something in the middle
and it's sticky and yummy it's like a
caramel waffle cookie delicious got like
a crunch when you first bite into it
then I was exhausted
I would definitely recommend this highly
bow to Nick little on earth
look at this kid on the front he's
having a blast like it stretches
oh god that's gross probably shouldn't
eat this it's like I've never had
anything cut the section before I don't
know what it is tastes like Jagermeister
it's bad fabulous
not a fan I let go up I mean I like
playing with it more than I like eating
it rotor goop it looks like old tofu
it's a slightly orgasmic it's
interesting texture to it yeah but my
finger on it pretty hard on the outside
and nice and soft on the inside it
tastes like a stick of butter yeah with
sugar in it it is pretty oily many
people say that it's delicious it is
it's really good it's someone to have
that last one out dog poop cadillacs oh
this smells so good can you get drunk
off of it and kids eat these Frank look
at these cars
isn't this kind of promoting during
driving in a way yeah work hard as a
rock
yeah I'm gonna have this later tonight
I'm sleeping this is like gummies for
adults like I'll be from Dillon John my
counts of gloom Bonin Jamaican rum
filled chocolates it just looked like
someone just pooped in a box do you
think it's gonna be rama's gonna come
out of this like a drunk probably Oh
Oh oh my god you just was like oh my god
it's strong - yeah that's not a joke
we've got to give it a little girl a
little warning here yeah I'm just about
to shoot something off like yeah it's
making me cry two point seven percent
alcohol I can taste it I wonder how many
it would take to get your like full-on
drunk you can get drunk off of your
whole package I don't know I liked it I
thought it's great
you get alcohol you get chocolate it's
just a little bit of everything I'm
offended by this can't you be honest I
wish I had let me know let me know if I
make this wall or